Hallo Stefan.
Ich hörs rascheln bei dir, das ist ja sehr ungewohnt. Ich lese heute auch das erste Mal wieder was auf Papier. Ich hab sie auf dem Schreibtisch liegen. Ist ja sehr ungewöhnlich, aber bei dir raschelt's.
Ja natürlich, ich lese ja gerne noch gedruckt.
Ja und du schreibst auch viel gedruckt. Ich hab gesehen, du hast in der NZZ wieder irgendwas geschrieben. Irgendwer ist gestorben.
Genau, wie bei Jean-Luc Godard. Den wichtigsten Regisseur. Der wichtigste Regisseur Stefan, man muss es dir nochmal sagen, ist nicht Michael Bay.
Nein.
Sondern ist Jean-Luc Godard.
Sagenmenschen, ja, hab ich irgendwie gehört.
Sowas kann man in der NZZ noch ganz offen schreiben. Warum raschel ich hier mit der Zeitung? Weil ich ein Interview im Freitag gelesen habe, mit Def Lewis, der ist 29 und der ist Sinotechnologe in Shanghai, beschäftigt sich auch mit den Corona-Apps und und und. Und der fängt dann so in diesem Interview an, na ja, jetzt, wo die Pandemie vorbei ist, und er wird dann auch gleich unterbrochen, wie vorbei. Also bei uns ja. Ach nee, das muss man jetzt vorsichtiger formulieren, sagt er dann. Und dann sagt er Folgendes. In Shanghai hatten wir vor zwei Wochen den ersten Fall nach fünf Monaten. Am Tag, nachdem das berichtet worden war, trat ich vor die Haustür. Die Hälfte der Leute trug sofort wieder Maske. Drei Tage lang waren Vorsicht und Angst zu spüren. Aber sie haben etwa am Flughafen alle getestet. Es traten nicht mehr als vielleicht fünf Fälle auf. Also haben alle die Masken wieder abgenommen.
Ja, das ist spektakulär, wenn ich mir jetzt manchmal so vorstelle, wir würden die Zeit noch mal zurückdrehen, auf Juli oder so. Wo wir beim RKI lesen, oh, heute wieder 300 Fälle in Deutschland. Und man würde jetzt unter Wissen, was im Herbst gerade los ist, sagen, okay, Leute, dann lass uns das jetzt mal auf drei pro Tag runterbringen. Das würden, glaube ich, sehr viele Leute mitmachen und einfach ihre Maske mal konsequent tragen. Stattdessen haben wir diese Chance verpasst. Das ist dieser asiatische Vorsprung, SARS 1 wahrscheinlich. Diese Alarmierzeit. Komm, wir haben es schon auf 300, jetzt machen wir drei. Nee, haben wir nicht gemacht, wir dachten irgendwie dran, das ist cool. Wenn es sich verdoppelt, dann dauert es ja bis Weihnachten, bis es 20.000 sind. Nichts war, ja. Aus einer deren Sicht. Aber gut, wir gehen jetzt in den Salon rein. Ich habe nur einen Text, der mit Covid zu tun hat.
Ich auch nicht. Wir reden über ein sensationelles Interview von Emmanuel Macron und über Weltraumrecht. Und wir sprechen über das Silicon Valley. Das ist wirklich ein Buch, das noch mal augeneröffnend ist. Selbst wenn man sich schon jahrelang mit dem Silicon Valley beschäftigt, ist es noch mal ganz klar herauskristallisiert, was dort eigentlich Denken genannt wird, aber dann eigentlich kein Denken ist.
Genau, das machen wir gleich als Erstes. Und danach, ich bin heute ein bisschen auf Rentenalpublik getrimmt, reden wir über Hörgeräte, die Krieg der Hörgeräte in Deutschland, Wirtschaftskriege werden meistens übersehen oder überhört, diese auch. Und Marxisten und Millionäre in Personalunion, das wird interessant. Okay, dann gehen wir mal in den Salon. Ihr, die ihr das gerade frei hört, hier noch mal der Hinweis auf, zum einen grundsätzlich den Salon. Und am 28.12.10 Uhr sind wir hier verabredet, um die große Jahresrückblicksschose zu machen. Das wird dann per Video live gestreamt im Salon. Das Video bleibt auch im Salon. Als Audioausgabe kommt das natürlich dann am Abend oder am nächsten Morgen ganz normal, wie zu erwarten. Es wird weniger um den Dezember gehen, sondern nochmal um die großen Themen des Jahres. Es sei denn, es passiert im Dezember nochmal Erstaunliches. Aber ich glaube, der Überraschungsmonat war der November. Der Dezember scheint jetzt so dahin zu plätschern. Also bietet sich dann auch an, nochmal so ein Jahr rekapitulieren zu lassen. Okay, dann auf in den Salon. Und ich hoffe, ihr kommt alle mit, denn wir sehnen herbei den 1500. Schwellenüberschreiter. So kann man sagen. Wellenbrecher und Schwellenüberschreiter. Okay, dann bis gleich, Leute.